Well, let's go try them out.
This "put your finger on the state method" is actually pretty much how you do it.
You start here in the start state, and then we see an a,
so we move over here.
We see a 1. We move over here.
We're out of input in an accepting state. This totally works!
How about 'aa'?
We start in state 1. We see an a. Great! We move to state 2.
We see the next a--oh! We fall off the finite state machine and die. No such luck.
'2b'--we start here in state 1. We see a 2. We immediately fall off and die. Not very good.
The empty string--we start in state 1. We don't go anywhere because we're out of input.
But state 1 is not an accepting state, so we don't accept this string.
'cc3'--start here in state 1. We see a c. We go to state 2. We see another c. We fall off.
'44d'--we start here in state 1. We see a 4. We fall off immediately.
In fact, only 'a1' matched out of all of these.